it is exceptionally difficult to make a
video on a divisive subject when it is
so fresh for me as a content creator I
know that there's absolutely no way on
Earth this video will be unanimously
enjoyed regardless of what I say there
will be someone who takes issue with it
that's true of any kind of review but
with something so fresh in this case
Attack on Titan's ending emotions are
still very high and people are
incredibly vocal unwilling to let go of
those initial feelings to approach the
subject with Nuance this is both
understandable and a little frustrating
frustrating because it actually masks
what the general consensus is angry
people are both loud and Relentless and
it can often take many months for things
to quiet down and for the larger picture
to emerge one of the most recent
examples of this is the video game The
Last of Us too prior to launch spotty
leaks lacking the greater context of the
story emerged leading to an early
feeling of Anger from certain parts of
the Gaming Community the game launched
and those people got louder and louder
and if you were to engage with
discussion around that game within the
first few weeks or simply consumed
nothing but hyperbolic or disingenuous
memes you might get the impression that
the game was an irredeemable failure
from start to finish of course you look
at things nowadays with the unsavory
parts of the fandom largely ignored and
the Situation's a lot more nuanced than
that which might have been apparent it
has broken sales records garnered
Universal critical praise and continued
to win countless Awards many of which
were voted on by fans Gamers vocally
praised it across social media and while
there are absolutely those with
incredibly strong negative opinions
concerning it of which they are entirely
valid and feeling the general response
to the game is so much more balanced and
nuanced nowadays now that might sound
like a somewhat strange tangent but
really it's a roundabout way of me
trying to say the intensely negative
reactions to attack on Titan's ending
that are circulating the internet right
now may not necessarily reflect how the
greater population feels as a whole or
it could be like Game of Thrones where
everyone Under the Sun despises the
ending and the whole thing isn't
entirely soured you are my queen
nothing will change that we'll see I
guess but as it currently stands Attack
on Titan's ending is one of immense
magnitude it is dense nuanced symbolic
it is one with tremendous thematic
impact and filled to the brim with
tragic uncertainty and yet it is
likewise clumsy rushed and borderline
juvenile at times you may sit either
side of the fence or you may be
somewhere in the middle but either way I
hope you'll take the time to consider my
perspective as I will yours and maybe
together we'll gain a greater
understanding of what this conclusion 11
years in the making truly offers this is
Attack on Titan's highly controversial
Final Chapter toward the tree on that
Hill
[Music]
for dozens upon dozens of chapters
readers of Attack on Titan had been
privy to a version of Aaron Yeager that
spawned from years of suffering a child
forced and tragedy who began to sink
deeper and deeper into darkness Longing
For Freedom convinced of the world's a
redeemable nature he became a character
that readers understood wholeheartedly
deeply empathized with but ultimately
and very reasonably considered to be in
the wrong standing strong with the likes
of Armin and his cohorts the notion that
violence begets more violence has been a
long-standing mantra for readers of this
franchise this Final Chapter however
recontextualizes everything we've ever
seen while simultaneously maintaining
the very high tragedy we all fell in
love with in the first place
in a lengthy conversation between Aaron
and Armin we come to understand the
truth of Erin Geiger's tragedy one of
immeasurable ways and heartbreak we come
to learn that upon touching historia's
hand at the awards ceremony at the end
of season 3 Aaron gained total
omniscience the power to see everything
that is was and will be he gained a full
understanding of the world's face along
with emir's memories and emotions and
all that her powers entailed and with
that came a horrific curse he saw the
endless possibilities the inevitable
outcomes and after exploring each and
every path he came to understand that
there was but One Singular path he must
keep pushing towards if he were to ever
achieve his goal for those of you who
are intimately familiar with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this shouldn't be A
New Concept in Avengers Infinity War
Doctor Strange looks into the future at
the millions of possible outcomes in
their predicament with Thanos and
discovered that there is a singular
outcome in which they prevailed this is
a fundamentally the same concept in
Attack on Titan though steeped in its
unrelentingly oppressive World while we
as readers had previously come to
believe Aaron's unjust actions were the
result of his internal logic Twisted by
his harrowed surroundings this
Revelation recontextualizes Aaron's
motives instead spitting a tale of a man
cursed with knowledge forced to
ostracize himself and turn against
everyone he ever loved or cared about in
the pursuit of freedom freedom for his
friends and freedom for his people
perhaps the most tragic action unveiled
here is the understanding that Aaron
caused the death of his own mother in
chapter 96 of the manga we see that the
Titan Dina encroaches upon Berthold and
yet she walks straight past him 40
chapters later we come to understand
that it was Aaron who saved berto's life
here in this instance honestly it's a
concept that's hard to comprehend and
these types of time manipulation stories
are never easy unfortunately but I'll do
my best to explain it to the best of my
understanding and hopefully it's largely
correct within the paths all events
occur on a fixed timeline and everything
happens in the same instant this is why
Aaron can still affect things that have
already happened since he is perceiving
everything all at the same time likewise
in terms of the predetermined Fates
mentioned in this chapter Aaron's mother
will always die and Berthold will always
die and there's no way to change that
this is evident in chapter 131 where
although Aaron's saves the young boy
Ramsay from being murdered by street
thugs he acknowledges the pointlessness
of his actions as the boy will still
ultimately die later via the rumbling
what's important to understand however
is that things can be delayed and
shifted around or manipulated to an
extent this is seen in Aaron's
manipulation of Grisha to take the
founding Titan for example what's tragic
in this reveal here however is that the
way in which Aaron's mother died had to
be this way for it to serve as Aaron's
motivator and bertol's death as a result
had to be prolonged for this part of the
story to play out in a way that leads to
the ideal outcome Aaron is pushing
towards that outcome being his death at
the hands of a very special person all
alone Aaron could do nothing but ensure
the wheels of Fate kept turning to the
exact specification required to hit the
outcome of freedom and so to put it as
simply as possible Aaron is looking down
at a great puzzle capable of forming
many pictures but only one specific
combination of those puzzle pieces will
produce the picture Aaron is seeking and
that picture is freedom Aaron continues
to issue his reasoning and Armin
explaining the Crux of his dilemma
emir's inescapable connection to King
Fritz abused from her very birth ymir's
life has been one of never-ending
ill-treatment and exploitation not once
has she experienced normality and in
spite of the horrific acts enacted on
her by the king her understanding of
Love Never wavered her resolve worn away
and beaten down Ymir is left incapable
of fathoming a world where she does not
obey her abuser and so she continues to
maintain the existence of titans in the
world prolonging the curse of her people
which means for this tragic cycle to end
for these chains of Fate to ultimately
break Aaron must follow along on the
singular path he witnessed that leads to
Salvation the key to the lock on that
chain is none other than Mikasa yamir is
so desperate to be released from the
agony of her love found a sort of
indirect kinship in Mikasa throughout
this story mikasa's love for Aaron has
been so strong to the point that she
actively values him over everything else
even her own life as Armin so succinctly
pointed out isiyama even goes as far as
to create a direct parallel with King
Fritz saying to Emir in an earlier
chapter Emir my slave and Aaron
repeating two Mikasa in their
confrontation you're a slave Mikasa both
Shackled slaves to love emir's choice in
Mikasa is both understandable and
pivotal in the events that follow as
Amir watches mikusa's actions over the
course of the narrative her
understanding of their shared
perspective on Love Grows stronger and
in those final moments as mikusa casts
aside her love for Aaron to do the right
thing in putting him to death behind her
stands none other than Emir a smile on
her face as she realizes that if Mikasa
could shed her love for the greater good
then perhaps she could too and that is
precisely what she does eradicating the
Titans and setting the eldians free and
when relayed like this I find that
attack on Titan's resolution is
remarkably powerful building upon years
of strong themat a character writing all
coming to a head wrapping up in
exceptionally tragic lore unfortunately
the clarity of this narrative both in
its dialogue quality and presentation of
events is where this Final Chapter Falls
flat and it's where I imagine a great
deal of the online animosity stems from
well I'm confused is this a happy ending
or a sad ending it's an ending that's
enough despite the chapter's rather
lengthy 50 pages only 20 of those are
dedicated to the content I've outlined
thus far with the remainder delegated to
short Snippets of character moments and
details of the finale's aftermath while
those remaining 30 pages are to me the
strongest parts of the chapter it's
those initial 20 that serve as the
resolution to Aaron's character Arc and
the greater conflict that the series has
hinged on since its inception for such
important subjects to be crammed into
such a short amount of time is
incredibly disconcerting and where I
believe the biggest flaws of this ending
stem from when dealing with complex
subjects it's vital to speak plainly and
to present your views with plot threads
that can be tied together naturally
while reading that's not to say media
can't be challenging thought-provoking
or require multiple viewings to truly
grasp but the emotional impact of a
piece of media is greatly diminished if
the majority of your audience is focused
on the logistics behind your story's
mechanics then living the emotions of
the scene along with the characters and
so contained with only 20 Pages much of
the expository dialogue here feels
remarkably brief and undercooked and as
a result arma's reactions begin to feel
the same way the structure largely
features arm and relaying the basics of
what's happening with Aaron dropping
large plot bombs and not really
elaborating on them further it's
important to give audiences time to
breathe take in major plot points and
assess them in the greater context of
the story but that's not what happens
here readers have barely had a chance to
ingest the reveal of emir's Stockholm
syndrome before Aaron reveals mikas's
importance one page later there's a
single page to breathe before the
exceedingly complex concept of time is
dropped on us which is Then followed up
by the reveal regarding Aaron's mother a
second later and characters are having
big emotional outbursts and none of that
works because justifiably readers cannot
be invested in the emotion of a scene if
they're still busy processing the prior
points Aaron has this moment of total
fragility as he breaks on the subject of
Mikasa heart broken over his fate to
never be with her he wants to feel his
presence is still in the world long
after he's gone particularly in mikus's
mind the person who's being his number
one since the story's Beginnings the
concept behind this scene is largely not
an issue but the way it's placed in this
chapter and given no surrounding context
is with no real lead in or lead out to
bring readers back around to this
version of Aaron the Outburst feels
quite silly and juvenile when its intent
is to be heartbreaking it's the same
issue that plagues many of armin's
reactions here particularly the famous
lion where he thanks Aaron for becoming
a mass murderer for the sake of their
future and okay while I do feel that in
general the way that that line is raised
is quite bad the intent behind it is
powerful having come to understand the
horrific sacrifices made Armin Once
Driven by dialogue over violence finally
understands the truth of Aaron's actions
and thanks him for enduring his cursed
Destiny it's a Reconciliation between
two friends that have drifted apart but
it just doesn't land and it should with
neither of them addressing the residual
faults in each other it all feels a bit
Hollow and understandably you have
readers asking why a b and c were never
addressed now I'm not gonna sit here and
try to dictate to you all how I feel the
chapter should have been written Point
by point I mean I think isiam has proven
his competency over the past 11 years
and suggesting that I could do better
would be immensely disrespectful but I
don't think it'd be particularly unfair
to say that this chapter could have
benefited from being split into two 40
to 50 pages dedicated to the explanation
of events a version that features a
nuanced buildup of these complex
emotions changing as Aaron transparently
elaborates on his his torturous time
throughout the series a version that
allows digestion time and breathing room
and allows these morally complex themes
to be explored in ways that best fit the
characters involved those initial 20
pages are exclusively where my major
issues with this ending lie and the
remainder at least to me are almost
perfect containing the most significant
emotional payoffs of the series
fulfilling themes in the making for all
these years returning to their human
forms the victims of these previous
chapters regain their memories coming to
understand Aaron's intentions in the
same way readers just witness Armin
doing it's a powerful moment
particularly with the likes of Annie and
Reiner finally reuniting with their
families this time with a hug and a lot
less tragedy heck Falco and Gabby's
reunion is so powerful that she straight
up suplexes him with no remorse alas
however the surface level happiness is
underpinned with pain and sorrow and
that's a running theme for this ending
against the background of these happy
reunions is a farewell as Armin amikosa
more the loss of Aaron and discuss the
best place to honor his memory far away
from those who'd interfere with a proper
send-off likewise in what is perhaps the
most emotionally resonant moment in this
Final Chapter Levi Connie and John
reflect on the symbolic visions of their
lost comrades allowing themselves One
Last Farewell dozens upon dozens of lost
lives all leading to this outcome and
Levi left permanently scarred he
wistfully utters I guess this is the
result of all of your devoted Hearts the
Mantra of the survey corps issued One
Last Time against the backdrop of human
sacrifice it's one of the most
beautifully Bittersweet moments of this
series and I can't help but feel
emotional just relaying it to you all
right now one last synchronized fist to
the heart as the fallen heroes of his
story vanish into the mist of the
aftermath leaving behind a shadow of the
Wings of Freedom and it's that sense of
Freedom that resonates throughout the
remaining pages of this story whether
the Marlins truly trust that the Titan
threat is gone is left ambiguous and
ultimately that's the point they're
allowed to live and for the first time
they're given a chance at life for many
fans the reveal that the identity of
historia's child's father was a red
herring has been a source of major
disappointment and while I can't
understand that to an extent I think the
purpose of that child has been sorely
misunderstood for me turning the page to
reveal a three-year time skip against
the backdrop of an eldian child
celebrating her third birthday in total
normality was such a thematically
powerful reveal that any misgivings of
being misled simply vanished a sign of
fearless normality in a warlike Attack
on Titan sends a powerful message to
readers about the success of Aaron's
actions and Page by Page the remaining
panels dictate the state of the world
three years after the climactic battle
end this is where the nuances of the
story most clearly come to light after
all the struggles Aaron went through all
the pain the suffering and the death war
continued used to rumble across the land
so what was Aaron really fighting for
it's here that I think the obvious
parallels to watchmen's Doctor Manhattan
are important to consider much like
Aaron Dr Manhattan has an omniscient
sense of time and one of his most famous
quotes is I can change almost anything
but I can't change human nature but I
think that notion is incredibly
pertinent to Aaron's actions within the
story War has always and will always be
a thing human Nature's sense of
tribalism is deeply ingrained and that's
not going away anytime soon but that was
never Aaron's goal he was never trying
to tie a neat bow on the world's issues
and vanish into the sunset as the sole
savior of the world Aaron's primary
concern has always been about freedom
and that's precisely what he provided
for his people the aldians the people of
paradise they're on a Level Playing
Field with the remainder of the world
now after centuries of being perceived
as monsters they're beginning to be seen
as people the Titans once a horrifying
tool for the Apocalypse used to frighten
the other nations are now gone for good
these people are free from the recurring
fate of suffering and now stand on equal
footing using their traumatic story to
underpin the campaign for peace in the
world Mass genocide happened it's a
thing and it will need to be
acknowledged and while armies are built
by those in fear of retaliation there
now exists a worldwide curiosity about
the people a paradise's message of Peace
a message of freedom and that's
precisely what makes the final pages of
this story so powerful as Mikasa sits by
Aaron's grave longing to see him again a
bird appears tugging at her scarf and
wrapping it over her shoulder throughout
the series the wings of a bird have been
a symbol for freedom The Hope For All
Mankind and for Aaron to appear
symbolically in this way and hearken
back to the Comfort he provides Mikasa
and now all of mankind that is one heck
of a powerfully resonant final image to
leave the series on taking all of that
into consideration unfortunately
thematic consistency can only take
quality so far when the presentation of
these aspects is such a mixed bag and
sadly That Remains the chapter's biggest
flaw it's something I think is worth
thinking about though it's easier to
make fun of something than to try and
understand it and I think people in time
as the conversation online becomes more
honest we may all arrive at similar
conclusions that attack on Titan's
ending isn't Game of Thrones it isn't
throwing away years of transparent
character arcs ignoring unfinished plot
threads and bending over backwards to
justify its conclusions the final
chapter is obtuse under baked and rushed
but what it isn't is a betrayal of its
Legacy a legacy that reminds us that the
ashes of Destruction can stand for more
than sorrow they can mark the birthplace
of a new era one of reflection and new
opportunity through all the suffering
comes eventual relief and the potential
for change it's a message that resonates
in many aspects of Life both within the
pages of this manga and the real world
and while I so wish that this ending had
more room to breathe to say what it
wanted to say with perfect clarity I
can't say it was a failure and with all
said and done
I still love Attack on Titan
oh thanks for watching guys last week's
video was one of the most challenging
projects I've ever attempted in the
history of my channel and I'd like to
once again extend a special thank you to
all of my patreon supporters for their
unwavering support and specifically to
anime AJ for writing this week's video
so that I could sleep this week in
addition to that one name I neglected to
shout out last week was a fantastic
Channel by the name of literal Maverick
his analysis of the political
controversy surrounding the series
proved to be invaluable when creating
that particular section in my previous
video and he's a great guy so please
check out his channel but now that I've
completed Attack on Titan in the truest
sense of the word it's time for my next
big adventure next week I'm diving head
first into one of the most beloved and
troubled Series in Japan next week I'm
starting the legendary Hunter Hunter
[Music]
thank you
[Music]